hello again and welcome back to the
gadget lab show I am Michael colori I'm
Christina Bonnington in a minute we're
going to talk about vine the new video
sharing that but first we're going to
talk about apple earnings yes now Apple
released earnings what Wednesday
Wednesday were you on the conference
call I was so I got to listen to Tim
Cook and Peter Oppenheimer talk about
apple earnings old superstars did you
get the opportunity to ask a question no
only analysts get to ask questions it's
kind of lame reporters just get to
listen in on the call that's probably a
good thing it probably is it although
the analysts tend to come off is sort of
soonish don't they sometimes you know
gene munster who's always he's a big
proponent of apple TV apples working on
a television basically asked him cook if
they were working on a television and
Tim totally sidestepped and ignored the
question basically a funny name is what
you keep asking me questions I can't
answer I think that's what he said yeah
yeah uh so what what's the big the big
news to come out of it so talking points
I mean of course um you know Apple made
an ungodly amount of money of profits of
13 point 1 billion but the thing was
this is the first quarter in the past
decade that Apple's revenue 55 billion
was lower than previous quarters Apple's
just been growing growing growing
growing for the past 10 years and this
is kind of the first like you know like
halt to that growth and then the stock
tanked yeah and so analyst really stuck
tight people are all like freaking out a
little bit but you know it doesn't as
far as like Apple the consumer brand the
the product company doesn't really
change much I mean they sold something
like 23 million iPads and 48 million
iPhones and this is the quarter spanning
from october to December so include the
holidays and just after the iphone 5s
launch which is something like seven
days shorter than previous quarters yeah
as well mmm this one had 13 weeks and
last year this quarter had 14 weeks okay
so that makes a difference in the
numbers a little bit now I have like an
irrational fear of
financial news oh you put a dollar sign
in the headliner and I won't read it
yeah but this has been fascinating me
just because I mean here's this company
that the largest technology company in
the world largest corporation in the
world making you know hand over fist
more money than anybody else exceeding
most expectations except for there's
this weird structure in Wall Street that
sets people up with expectations that
are you know different than somebody who
doesn't study finance would expect a
company to say this is good or this is
bad performance yeah so basically all
these analysts have these models and
when apple doesn't meet their models
like you know it's like oh sell sell
sell and stuff yeah it's a little i'm
not i wouldn't call myself an expert on
that sort of stuff but it's definitely
been interesting to follow especially
this quarter so if you're not
shareholder you're just a consumer or in
our case if we're you know talking about
the news i think for me the important
things with it Tim Cook did address some
of the the news stuff yes you dress some
rumors you talked a little bit about the
about the rumors about supply chain yeah
apple iphone 5 component orders being
cut yeah basically said the supply chain
is so so complicated like if even if you
got one correct data point there's no
way you could extrapolate this means
that iphone 5 demand is waning or
something you know there's just like
they use so many different suppliers so
many different parts there's so many
moving components in the supply chain
that you know it's kind of bogus yeah
and and there were no product
announcements no product is there never
are during during calls although
everybody was asking for them I don't
know yeah I mean people ask questions
about you they'll ask forward-looking
questions and apple doesn't really
address those they'll sidestep them okay
so let me ask you once the iphone 6 come
out so I mean iphone 6 i don't know i
mean i think that i think the word on
the street is we're gonna have an iphone
5s first you know same form factor as
the iphone 5 but with you know improved
parts and stuff kind of like we saw with
the 4s last year and some people are
thinking this summer well it's
dreadfully boring yeah this summer or
the fall okay well thank you for your
update on apple
I know we usually don't talk about
finance on the show but it was such a
big story and actually really important
to the way that Apple does business and
how different Apple is from the other
consumer technology companies that we
cover so it's important that we talk
about it and now we're going to talk
about something you can download onto
your iphone which is fine and we're
going to be Alexander to talk about that
oh right Alexander joins us to tell us
all about vine right it's a
video-sharing app that is owned by
twitter and it just launched basically
it's very similar to other video sharing
apps except for a few unique little
twists such as such as its limited every
clip is limited to six seconds and also
when you're recording you can like make
it really easy to stop and go while
you're tapping the screen basically it's
happened to start tap it to stop so a
lot of what we're seeing ends up looking
like gifts or stop motion animation yeah
people are actually creating stop-motion
animator cool it it looks really cool so
to shoot a frame you just tap like that
but to shoot like a secession of frames
you hold your finger down for a couple
seconds and you only get six seconds and
then there's also a minimum of like 2.5
seconds so you can't just do a little
photo video thing yeah they're sort of
they're sort of like moving images
they're very very very much like
animated gifts mhm which i think is
really smart I think so too because when
you get into the app you don't have to
press play or anything like that you
just scroll through a list of these
looping videos and it just automatically
starts playing for you so it's really
easy to use it's easy to shoot and I
think it you know sort of solves this
whole thing with video sharing apps not
really keeping their user base for very
long because it takes so much effort
yeah and there's a bandwidth issue right
with moguls you know like shooting video
and uploading video and videos so heavy
this makes it super lightweight super
easy and it's it's a lot i think the
interface is totally brilliant but it's
pretty it's definitely pretty and also
just the idea that you hold your thumb
down mm-hmm tissue
and then you lift your thumb up and then
you know you can rearrange a scene you
can wait for something else interesting
to happen it's opens up all kinds of
really cool right options so it's not
just like everybody's posting videos of
their cat sitting there you know they
could do their cat sitting and then
their cat somewhere else yeah and then
no it's more creative yeah and even
though it's owned by Twitter it's not a
Twitter exclusive app you can still post
to Facebook you can connect with friends
on Facebook you can totally have no
other social networks connected to it so
they're just trying to make it easier to
sign in with twitter even though I
couldn't sign in with twitter yeah
there's a little bit of bugginess right
it's still new so there's still a couple
of bugs to figure out but other than
that it's really light easy quick to use
and it's fun and it's I was only right
but they're saying that's going to come
to other platforms soon as always we
would expect Android hopefully very very
soon probably not windows phone probably
not windows phone although it's it's
pretty perfect for the demographic that
Windows Phone is going after it yeah
young people yeah because people people
I think you are a little bit older
people who have been you know shooting
video on their phones for a long time
are still a little weirded out by mine
because well you can't really edit it's
not very powerful well it's not the
point right the point is like this is
it's like snapchat it's like an animated
gif builder it is very little relation
to video other than the images move
mm-hmm that's about it I think kind of
like Instagram kinda like in skin looks
a lot like Instagram and I think it's
what do you think is it gonna be as big
as Instagram was it gonna be is it has
potential I think it definitely has the
potential to people can I make my videos
look like 1982 no okay well then we'll
see about the updates thanks so much
thank you and we got to have you on the
show more girl was delight yeah thanks
all right we'll see you next time on
gadget lab
you